a Democrat facing Mayors or blowback
over her gun grab a federal judge
issuing a temporary restraining order
gutting key parts of New Mexico Governor
Michelle Lujan grisham's 30-day ban on
carrying firearms in public places and
this is just the beginning of her
headache the state's Democrat attorney
general said he's going to refuse to
represent her office in the cases citing
his oath to the Constitution ow
and the sheriff who oversees the county
where she wants the gun ban flat out
says he's not going to enforce it the
temporary man challenges the foundations
of our constitution
but most importantly it is
unconstitutional
my oath was to protect the Constitution
and that is what I will do this order
will not do anything to curb gun
violence other than punish law-abiding
citizens for the constitutional right to
self-defense I have a fact for you
criminals do not follow the law
or a public health order but it looks
like the liberal Governor doesn't care
what her critics say
my question to law enforcement is where
are you it's not for police to tell me
what's constitutional or not they
haven't supported one not one gun
violence effort in the state of New
Mexico Governor recruiting domestic
violence protections Universal
background checks
Greg what do you call when you say you
want to do something and everybody just
runs away uh let's go watch Jesse water
show
I love the two things these are physical
uh I I I can do this the sheriff has the
best bald head I've ever seen in my life
I if I lose my hair I want that head
grisham's got crazy eyes it's pretty
clear we now have six different lawsuits
now I like lawyers what and I hate to
like lawyers that's like when someone
gives you a veggie burger and it kind of
tastes good and you're like what
happened Grisham might have just given
New Mexico to Trump you know I I really
I I mean it this was such a misstep
again it's it's another it's another
case where the Democrats who often
confuse the Republicans and Libertarians
and everybody else of doing things that
they do in this case it was like
stealing your rights they're actually
guilty of you see that with the First
Amendment Banning books speech it's
progressives the Second Amendment here
your rights to living a life as a parent
it's all coming from the progressives so
again the so-called constitutional
crisis that you keep hearing about on
the right is an illusion but on the left
it's a reality which is why I always
salute Tulsi for leaving the party and
it's really important because you can
tell all the people that are kind of
moving away from there are getting
targeted whether it's Tulsi or RFK Jr or
Russell Brand do you see Russell Brand
talking about Trump the other day that
was insane you got and you have other
great people out there Elon Musk Joe
Rogan they're all being targeted because
they realize that their rights are being
encroached upon
I appreciate the fact that you're making
comments about people's physical
character I think I learned that from
you I think it's about time we all
joined together at the table to do that
Chelsea you were just mentioned yes is
this going to make people Democrats walk
away from the Democratic party uh I
think we're seeing it happening in real
time here when you have the Democrat
attorney general you have the sheriff
you even have the ACLU there in New
Mexico coming out against what this
Governor has done I think it's very
telling of the direction that we're
headed in you know one thing that I
thought of and I know Governor Grisham
we serve together in Congress uh in the
military both in training and in combat
leaders are tested that when you're in a
situation uh Under Pressure will you
think clearly will you be able to make
decisions and still execute the mission
she's clearly Under Pressure but she is
acting frantically and nonsensically
basically saying literally well
somebody's got to do something and I am
doing something I am taking bold action
without any thought for okay well what
is the Constitution of the United States
say what is the constitution of her own
State say both she's violating both with
this so-called Public Health Emergency
that she's ordered and even admitted to
a local reporter who said hey Will
criminals abide by your temporary ban
she said no she sees it uh it's yeah
it's it's insane Dana did she just light
her political future on fire I think
that she thought she was giving it a
real boost and instead what she has done
is basically set the anti-gun movement
back by a lot because so she's extremely
unpersuadable if you have the ACLU
saying yeah you're crazy that is
probably not very good for you
um and the other thing is to tulsi's
point she didn't even talk to anybody in
the state beforehand so now she's at
odds with her own attorney general and
the police and now she's flailing around
saying but why isn't anybody else doing
something so I think that she had the
intention of saying well I'm going to
get to the left of Gavin Newsom like
they all see the writing on the wall
they think that Joe Biden's not going to
make it so they're trying to figure out
how could I get some attention and what
is the issue that will help me get
attention and they also have a very big
and bad problem in New Mexico on crime
but it's not the legal gun owners who
are causing that problem it's the fact
that they're not Prosecuting the crimes
and getting people put in prison how bad
does it have to get when the Attorney
General says
defend the governor yeah I'm not going
to defend you uh Madam Governor the
interesting the good news about this
whole thing is everyone disagrees with
her and the shocking part of it is that
she is an attorney yeah and it stunts me
that she doesn't understand what it
takes to uh you know to to change a
constitutional amendment okay that it
takes what two-thirds of that both
houses of Congress or three quarters of
the ratification of the states I mean
she it doesn't even occur to her and
then she's out there trashing the police
the police haven't supported not one of
my legal go law enforcement efforts and
it's stunning to me and the police go
out there every day Michelle and put
their lives on the line and you want to
trash them and you don't really care
that the illegals aren't the guys with
illegal guns aren't going to listen to
you uh and you don't expect them to
listen to you and in fact a federal
judge has just put a hold on the uh on
the whole thing yeah the Judge David
Urias issued a temporary restraining
order prohibiting key parts of the
governor uh New Mexico Governor Michelle
Lujan grisham's Public Health order
declaring gun violence a public health
emergency uh I mean it's real clear to a
judge in a minute that this is
unconstitutional I think it's the end of
her career if she thinks that you know
people respect people who just don't
understand the Lord don't understand the
system she doesn't understand her own
system and uh if you can create a an
exception to the constitution on any
health emergency you can just create an
emergency to get rid of you know one of
the Amendments you sure can all right up
next the covid lab League cover-up gets
even worse a whistleblower makes an
explosive Claim about CIA agents and
bribery hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else